- When someone else is doing my makeup,
I'm just like, "You do it!
"You know exactly what you're doing."
- Yeah, well, you don't wanna
end up looking like a clown.
(disco music)
I'm gonna be distracting
them with conversation
to make sure they don't
know they're being pranked.
(disco music)
- I'm super excited
to see what I look like as Kylie Jenner.
- She has some really good selfies,
lots of confidence, which I love.
- This will be my first official makeover.
- For Michelle, I'm gonna hook her up
with some raccoon eyes
and some cat whiskers.
For Jade, we're gonna give her a nice
extreme orange tan.
I was thinking of
repositioning her eyebrows.
For Mallory, she has a very joyful face,
so I'm gonna make her into a clown.
(dramatic music)
- I can tell there's stuff on my face,
like, I have this extra kind of layer,
but it's not anything crazy.
I can understand how people
would get used to it.
(dramatic music)
- Oh, no!
(laughing)
Oh, shut up!
- Hold on. (laughing)
Oh, God.
Oh, God. (laughing)
- What?
Wait...
Wait, no,
what is this?
- Oh my gosh.
I kind of look like a
pumpkin that's been painted!
- Wait, this is what she does?
- Why do I look like a raccoon?
- I think the only thing
I like is the lipstick,
so maybe I'll snag that,
but my face is a totally different color
than the rest of my body.
- What?
I don't get it.
- Oh!
- This is a makeover from hell. (laughing)
- Well, 'cause I didn't
want insult Kylie Jenner.
I was like, "Oh my God, does
she have to do this every day?"
- I'm keeping the lashes.
I am gonna take the rest of
this off and leave the lashes.
- I'm really glad this isn't real.
I'm terrified of clowns on a normal basis,
so, I looked, I was like, "Oh, God!"
Have you seen the movie It?
(beep) that movie!